let's get into some phone calls at 6 1 7
8 3 0 47 50 see what's on people's minds
starting with our caller from the 4:07
area code caller from 4:07 what's your
name where are you calling from 80 David
my name is Josh I'm calling from the
Orlando area hey Josh what's going on
hey I just have a quick question about
your opinion so let's say for instance
Joe Biden wins the primary sure and
let's say either like Warren or Bernie
or yang kind of just goes to independent
they don't necessarily drop out yeah
would you suggest in this case to stick
with the Democratic vote or should you
let's say Biden's policies don't
necessarily align with mine yeah would I
go independent what would you suggest
mysterio this is a very difficult
reckoning that I actually doubt will
have to be done I don't think the
scenario you're suggesting is likely but
it's happened in the past and there is a
very good chance that mathematically if
you have Biden as the nominee and a
popular other candidate run third party
like Elizabeth Warren or Bernie Sanders
since they are the ones in second and
third place that mathematically that
could give reelection to Donald Trump
and I know people often you know this is
like a pragmatic ISM versus idealism
thing and there are people who are angry
at the mere mention of the fact that
this is the mathematical reality in many
cases I you know any action that leads
to Donald Trump's reelection that we
know in advance would do so is a hard
action to get behind although I
understand dissatisfaction with Biden as
the nominee if he ends up being one from
the progressive wing of the Democratic
Party so I I hope that that just simply
doesn't happen and I don't actually
think it will but it would be a very
difficult scenario in the end I don't
know that I cast a vote that helps
Donald Trump win now in NASA
I voted Massachusetts so in
Massachusetts I don't see any way for
anything other than the Democratic
candidate to win maybe in Massachusetts
I say I'll vote independent for Bernie
or Warren but nationally this could be
very dangerous
right yeah I tend to agree with what
you're saying so if this does happen
would you advocate for people to stick
with the Democratic vote to help Trump
get at office or would you kind of just
explain yourself this way and just urge
people to kind of you don't know that if
they go with the independent there
they're actually giving a vote to Trump
possibly yeah I think I think what I
would say is I would try to be very real
with the audience and I would say I
sense your frustration as a progressive
I think we've got to do the responsible
thing and if you're in a state that is
very clearly safe for the Democratic
nominee vote for whoever you like the
most even if it's third party there are
lots of states where we don't know that
it's safe for the Democratic nominee and
in those states I think you have to
think about do you want your vote to be
a vote that effectively helps reelect
Donald Trump and do what you think is
right I wouldn't tell anyone what to do
but you would have to understand that in
Michigan if you say I'll vote for Bernie
third party or I'll vote for Warren
third party you may be helping Donald
Trump win Michigan okay I got you okay
that was my question David I appreciate
you for answering it and longtime fan so
thanks for the material and I hope that
you put out more and continuing to put
out more thank you really appreciate the
call and the support and I hope to hear
from you again